welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and season 6
episode 6 of Rick and Morty is the last
episode we're gonna see for a hot minute
while the show takes a Hiatus despite
the fact that we had our only linked
evil Morty severed at the end of this
app I'm definitely going to spend the
next six weeks speculating about what
this means for the rest of the season
but for now I'm taking you frame by
frame through jurik sick more and
breaking down all the details you might
have missed let's start with the episode
title Drake sigmort is obviously a play
on Jurassic Park the tale of Humanity's
misguided attempt at making prehistoric
creatures part of the capitalist machine
and while I have a captive audience I'm
just gonna say it the Jurassic Park ride
at Universal was 10 billion times better
than the Jurassic World ride ever will
be correct Ezra flips through the
channels we catch a split second of a
commercial for eye holes beautiful
disgusting cereal from season 2 episode
8 interdimensional cable 2 tempting fate
he settles on TV 58 rgbh news which is
reporting that the giant Rift evil Morty
created in the central finite curve last
season is still hanging out when Morty
asks for a ride to school Rick offers
him the portal gun claiming that he
fixed it when he tries to use it however
the Cthulhu monster from the opening
credits pops out and redcastle Spritz it
with the same spray bottle I used to
teach Pugsley not to pee in the house
they give up and take the car after that
which is in remarkably good shape after
the shootout it went through in night
family Rick tries to convince Morty that
he's still in the process of fixing it
an answer that Morty chocks up to his
Grandpa's laziness interestingly towards
the end of the episode when asked how
they plan to reverse the meteorite the
dinosaurs answer that they are in the
process of figuring it out a response
unacceptable to Earth's people when
Morty walks into Mr goldenfold's math
class the Teacher Calls a Morty protocol
and the students glamor under their
desks like it's an earthquake drill
actually I think that we only do our
earthquake drills in California but I
don't want to say the words of the other
kind of drill and get flagged by YouTube
on the Blackboard there are multiple
math dicks drawn including one labeled
babies come from space in the upper
right hand corner you can see two names
on the detention list Morty s who is
clearly Morty Smith and Corey B AKA Cory
Booth the lead color designer for Rick
and Morty when The Invasion begins
golden fold asks Morty if he's been The
Faculty it again a reference to the 1998
sci-fi horror where High School teachers
get possessed by aliens the [ __ ] that
the dinosaurs arrive in look just like
the alien ships from 2016's arrival a
movie about a species of
extraterrestrial life that dropped 12
egg-shaped ships in different parts
across the Earth Amy Adams has to figure
out how to speak the heptopods language
in order to save these creatures and
themselves three thousand years in the
future in the same way that those aliens
wanted to help Humanity these dinosaurs
mission is to perfect the earth in every
way healing the earth and its people
these god-like dinosaurs were voiced by
actor Lisa Kudrow musician Jason Mraz
and Rick and Morty Creator Dan Harmon as
the T-Rex the brachiosaurus and the
Triceratops respectively we all know
Lisa Kudrow as the best friend but I had
no idea that the guy who wrote the
remedy was into voice acting you and I
both learned something new every day a
meeting is called by the world leaders
at the UN to discuss their new dine
overlords outside you can see flags for
the German State North rhine-westphalia
Spain the United Kingdom Brazil turkey
and America the dinosaurs explained that
they perfected Earth long ago and left
to go Aid other planets in need while
they were gone the rest of their species
was killed and humans repopulated the
Earth inventing horrible things like
gunpowder anime body pillows celebrity
presidents Jazzercise luteal implants
Marvel movies space tourism Dogecoin
social media comment sections domestic
terrorism Crocs Amazon Prime
fluffernutter sandwiches and capitalism
in their absence thankfully both the
president and this General are fans of
new rockstars and know that the Earth
didn't bow to Thanos and thousand we
won't battle them now but the dinos
offered a kick back relax and let them
destroy capitalism and global warming
does sound really nice so the president
student takes them up on their offer to
focus more on the new Ant-Man movie this
is a joke towards Rick and Morty writer
Jeff loveness aka the guy writing
quantumania as soon as the dino Gods
start healing the world a beautiful song
with a bunch of silly sounding but
totally real dinosaur names plays the
list includes Zuni saratop a nod to the
indigenous people from the Zuni River
Valley elvisaurus okay Elvis Presley and
Bambi Raptor a mashup of a deer with a
dead mom and a raptor then there's a
rectopus which means upright foot but
sounds like a Boner Garage followed by
dracoix hogwartzia a player on Draco
Malfoy and Hogwarts rounding out the
sound there's a gojirasaurus AKA
Godzilla falconadon for the Vulcans from
Star Trek zaraniops for Sauron from Lord
of the Rings and puyangus aorus named
after the puyang region of Thailand
where this Dino's bones were discovered
several newspapers are reporting on
Humanity's problems being erased we've
got the Syracuse Orange Peel the
Philadelphia answerer the Chicago
tribute the Trenton Taki Tribune and Los
Angeles places later on in the episode
we see this same newspaper Montage again
discussing the world's reversal to a
pre-dyno version of its messy self those
ones are called the Rutherford post
after the episode's writer Nick
Rutherford Levy Morning News after
co-executive producer Stephen Levy
Paget's Gazette the Washington
Chronicles and the Denver daily doses
all around the world folks are reverting
to their pandemic Hobbies like
crosswords crocheting and building fake
birdhouses but all is not as wonderful
as it seems Force surgeon Beth is so
bored she's playing and losing a
horse-themed game of operation and now
that all the bad men have been removed
from Tick Tock summer has nowhere to
post her dance videos I love the little
detail that when she throws her phone at
the wall you can see a dent made in the
plaster the only person truly thriving
is Jerry who's an absolute expert in
doing nothing he seizes the moment to
Sprint to his office and print a copy of
his manuscript titled never trying never
fails hoping that it'll speak to the
Lost masses the title of this book
definitely sounds like a yogaism Yogi
Berra a baseball player from the 40s had
a series of unintentionally brilliant
quotes and melopropisms recorded
throughout his lifetime for example it
ain't over time till it's over and
always go to other people's funerals
otherwise they won't go to yours or
popular quotes originated by him in
Jerry's office we see his golf poster
that reads life is rough that's appeared
in earlier episodes along with Garfield
desktop wallpaper and a bunch of
computer documents his folders are
labeled forgotten stuff forgotten stuff
too delete this and Titanic locations
calling back to Jerry's love of the
Titanic from season one while also
implying that he has some conspiracy
theories as to where it really sank he
also has a series of files in there like
an mp4 titled beekeepers Delight a video
of pandas falling pictures of a snake in
a mini skirt and an ugly dog and my
personal favorite Kamasutra from
middle-aged men ebook when he finally
finds his manuscript draft there are
three different documents labeled final
final and final final which is truly how
every single writer on this planet
especially at new rock stars labels
their scripts Jerry's book intro
explains that he's not an athlete or a
star in any way but he is capable of
sitting down and writing the book you're
holding so trust him we all also
explains his family noticeably leaving
Rick out of his description that's cold
he even acknowledged baby Naruto
although he clarified that he does not
like talking about his grandpa dumb and
you thought that there'd be a whole
episode this season without an incest
reference the president calls Rick to
barbecue a barbecue restaurant run by an
elderly man named Beau who as the sign
tells us knows ribs this restaurant is a
parody of Freddy's barbecue from House
of Cards the rib joined Frank Underwood
frequented unfortunately after asking
for Rick's help eliminating the aliens
Bo breaks down and the president accuses
Rick of westworlding him Westworld is a
TV show about sentient robots that real
people pay to spend time with but the
president is apparently more of a
YouTube guy anyone who does what we do
knows how goddamn everywhere Those
grammarly ads are President Curtis also
references Zero Dark 30 the dramatized
story of America's Manhunt for Osama Bin
Laden Rick agrees to help him but only
if he gets him a job hosting the Oscars
Rick approaches the dinos as their
mourning their fallen homies in an oil
field when he try offers help sending
them to another version of Earth they
informed him that they've been portal
jumping for eons and they've adapted a
one true Universe philosophy which makes
sense with infinite universes there are
infinite problems to solve best to focus
on cleaning up their home Universe first
the T-Rex hands Rick a brand new
high-tech portal pistol with clear
fluids so that he can see where he's
jumping Morty responds clever girl a
call back to that scene in Jurassic Park
where Muldoon gets gapped by Raptors
you're telling me to stop the video when
I'm so full of G fuel that I can't if
you like Rick and Morty staying hydrated
and feeling alert and energized have I
got news for you now you can pick up the
G fuel unstable portal fluid collector's
box inspired by Rick and Morty this
sweet juicy sour Strawberry Limeade
blend will hit the spot whether you're
tuckered out from a fun day a Jerry
Berry or just you know thirsty in
general the collector's box comes with a
tub and a shaker cup the tub has a bunch
of fan favorite characters like Mr
meeseeks and Mr Poopy butthole and
another fun Rick and Morty references
inside the tub you've got antioxidants
Focus aminos vitamins and other good
stuff to get you jump started on your
day G fuel also has all kinds of fun
energy and hydration formulas including
ones branded around the other content
you love click the link in the
description and use code new rockstars
to get 30 off your order thanks to
g-fuel for sponsoring this video
uninterested in any help that Rick and
Morty could offer them the dinosaurs
teleport them back to the garage Dr
Manhattan style as depicted in the film
adaptation of Watchmen on Rex desk you
can see the mind blower helmet from
season three episode eight and yes since
you're wondering 40 was right Rick did
have his fly down during that entire
scene back home Rick is pissed who do
these Gods think they are refusing his
help like he's not the smartest man in
the universe no good deed goes
unpunished baby so Rick decides to dig
deep into their prehistoric past to find
the truth about their world betterment
project like Sean Penn hiding his
violent and abusive past with political
activism these perfect Dino gods have to
be hiding something after Rick destroys
their brand new portal pistol out of
spite Morty begins reading the packet
the dinos gave to them in it are
testimonials from other planets that the
dinos have helped including to Morris
light Ronkonkoma and Alpha Centaurus
Rick realizes that these other planets
might hold the answer so after using his
wrist scanner to locate them he and
Morty decide to go on a little
interplanetary field trip he says this
to Morty they're gonna call us Laura
Dern because we're about to get elbow
deep in Dino doodoo a reference to the
scene in JP when Dr Ellie Sattler slips
into a pair of gloves and goes rooting
around and Triceratops poop after
failing miserably to pull a Tony Hawk
Pro Skater 3 and drop into the crater
Rick discovers a small chunk of sentient
meteorite and realizes that every planet
the dinosaur Gods visited ultimately
faced the same fate the Brachiosaurus
T-Rex and Triceratops perform a keynote
q a at what looks like Angel Stadium due
to the waterfall peeking out just behind
the Jumbotron if you ever visit
California check it out it's super weird
because Coors Light usually add
advertises just above the falls and I
like to believe that the fountain is
just filled with Stadium beer although
they introduced Jerry's book to the
masses they fail to credit him as the
author and Rick crashes the stage with
the new information he's gathered Rick
explains to the crowd that as the
dinosaurs grew more enlightened a
separate equally evil entity was formed
these giant meteorites would seek and
destroy the planets they had just
perfected and left behind forcing each
World Civilization to start over from
the primordial soup this species is
inspired by the moon from the Legend of
Zelda Majora's Mask now one of these
meteorites is headed straight for Earth
to destroy everything these guys have
worked so hard to build as soon as the
audience learns this they begin throwing
[ __ ] on stage including bricks plants
pizzas knives ninja stars Tomatoes
CD-ROMs water bottles rocks banana peels
and cups the dinosaurs begin their talk
show apology tour with Anderson 360
where they admit that they still don't
have a plan they're torn if they destroy
the meteorite they'll be committing
violence against another sentient life
form something that these vegans swore
long ago if they leave the planet
Humanity will once again devolve into
darkness undoing their hard work and
dooming themselves to more and more
Marvel movies when they appear on The
Joe Rogan Experience Joe is wearing a
DMT Rex shirt and drinking a CBD water
and Nod to two things he will match that
up about by the time they reach the
Wendy Williams Show the trio announces
that they're leaving the planet for good
which will hopefully draw the meteorite
away from Earth once again we get
another cheering around the world
Montage this time as the world spins
backwards into chaos there's riotin in
the streets capitalism is in full force
business guys are repairing their ties
and going back to work old dinosaur
statues are destroyed and a street is
renamed Dino sucks Avenue in their
dishonor as this all goes down we hear
another song This Time listing all the
problems in the world including the 1989
Exxon oil spill the asbestos
contamination of Libby Montana type 2
diabetes the Deepwater Horizon oil spill
garbage island and the extinction of
honeybees back at Buzz the president is
on Mali and on the TV at the bar you can
see a broadcast of the dinosaur ships
departing although he got Rick that
Oscar gig Rick refuses to bring him as a
plus one as Rick hosts the 95th annual
Academy Awards a butt ton of celebrities
can be seen in the crowd and listen
y'all I thought I was gonna have an easy
time identifying all of these because I
am constantly glued to the TV but I
actually had some trouble definitely hit
me up in the comments below and let me
know who I missed I want to know what
you guys think the celebrities I could
identify were Eva Mendes Adam Driver
Shonda Rhimes George Takei Tim Roth
Adrian Brody Ted Danson Susan Sarandon
The Rock Angelina Jolie Jason Momoa
Quentin Tarantino Uma Thurman Chloe Zhou
Johnny Carson Johnny Depp Matt Berry
Morgan Freeman Rita Wilson Tom Hanks and
Wes Anderson and I know what you're
thinking Johnny Carson is dead Whitney
how can he be at the 95th Oscars but if
you recall the vat of acid episode this
exact character model was used for
Carson also please note that Quentin
Tarantino is obviously gazing at
somebody's nearby feet probably why Uma
Thurman sat behind him she is sick of
his [ __ ] Henry Angelina Jolie the office
of new rockstars is very divided Eric
and I think it's her because of her lips
the producer John lovingly disagrees so
let me know your all theories for this
burnout Beauty in the comments when Rick
gets off stage he wipes the alcohol from
his mouth and soberly tells summer that
everything at the Oscars is scripted
even that one thing I'm not gonna say it
but I think we all know what thing he's
talking about bethan's face Beth run
into the dressing room excited to have
scored Swag Bags with gift cards to
Sprinkles Cupcakes in them but Rick has
to quit his dream gig when his
granddaughter tells him that the
dinosaurs are just standing on Mars with
their dicks in their hands you could say
that uh Jason Mraz Brachiosaurus is
waiting for his meteorite to come Rick
flies his ship to Mars because he still
hasn't fixed portal travel and tells the
dinosaurs Elon must be dimmed or blowing
up Mars he's even Dino proofed his texts
that they can't Dr Manhattan him back to
Earth while they wait for their entire
species to be wiped out after playing a
game of virtue chicken and the T-Rex
destroys the meteorite the first violent
act committed by dinosaurs and Millennia
Rick tells them that they're not allowed
to die just because they're smarter than
everyone else a reference to David
Foster Wallace a complicated genius
writer who took his own life in
retaliation for saving them against
their will the dinosaurs used their ship
to seal the rift in the central finite
curve in Raging Rick I'm like oh yeah
buddy this ruined your week you're not
the one who just got a million Theory
video ideas cut off halfway through the
season come on guys Mama could have
really use that sweet sweet
three-episode canonical Arc all jokes
aside this isn't the first time that the
Rick and Morty writers faked us out by
telling us that they weren't going to
expand any further on certain storylines
I don't believe them that Rift was far
too juicy a plot device to trash in 30
seconds and there's no way it's staying
closed and it turns out that Rick's old
portal gun isn't dead yet either after
exploding the garage he pulls a hat
wearing a human on its head out of
another dimension and kicks off what
promises to be a fresh batch of
shenanigans
including making his grandson
interdimensionally barf from portal to
portal he whips out Morty's boob World
hat and takes his grandson on a
well-earned vacay to areola week back in
the Smith's home the family is watching
forest fires rage on the news and summer
asks if she can turn the AC on because
global warming is back in the game
spacecraft is clear still hungover from
the Oscars and sucking down a bloody
mary summer announces that she has a new
tick tock follower named at crypto
forbertos which I'm pretty sure is Tommy
bechtel's Wiki feet handle Jerry on the
other hand has grown out a full-scale
depression beard and is once again
wallowing in nothingness I know his
story was just a b plot this episode but
it's actually pretty heartbreaking this
dude was perfectly happy just bopping
along in life when his unique specialty
was finally called upon in the planet's
hour of need just as he was starting to
feel important and hopeful the rug was
pulled out from underneath him his
authorship was discredited and the world
no longer needed his book yeesh for
Jerry finally the post-credits scene
catches up with the dino Gods who've
moved on to a new planet to call home as
soon as they arrive the Triceratops
announces that they want to I bet I
could switch hail onto that Mani pad big
spin out Trey flipped that Gap 5-0 the
rail drop into the bowl still fish into
a Chrysler and then we all get it's on
Iguanodon this is a list of skateboard
moves that I don't know how to do but
because I'm trapped in a blue dungeon
turns out dinosaurs skateboard who knew
I mean besides the guys from alpha
Centaurus follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at whitneypuppy follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]